so I'm Nicholas and I work at Twitter I
recently joined the web core team there
I worked there with Brett who helped
organize this with Jonathan a Nicole and
I kind of ended up with the opportunity
to work it with it because I spent a lot
of time working on open source software
when I was working on open source stuff
we've got to meet a lot of really
interesting people who taught me a lot
about how to do web development
introduced me to other interesting
people and introduced me to all kinds of
different projects that were going on
one thing that really struck me was the
speed at which things were changing all
the time and pretty quickly I realized
that the thing that was holding me back
was not how quickly I could change the
code that I was working on but how
quickly I could adapt my way of thinking
to sort of accommodate all the other
stuff that was going on so when I first
started to learn how to do web
development which was like about five
years ago CSS was kind of the easy part
to work with initially once you learn
syntax and you learn how to make a you
know a button look red or whatever and
you think that you kind of know most of
what there is it's like this is pretty
easy to work with but four years later
by the time I joined Twitter what was
about to join Twitter I'd already lied
that working on CSS for large teams and
large web applications was a pretty
painful process and since I've joined
Twitter I've had the chance to write
more JavaScript and learn more about the
JavaScript world and work on to live CSS
code bases one for a tweet deck which I
helped rewrite and the other one which
is twitter com I realized that working
with CSS in some ways is probably like
one of the worst parts of being web
developer is really difficult to work
with because you have to kind of
maintain an awareness of how the whole
thing is put together in your mind or as
at least with JavaScript there are ways
to kind of work in small encapsulated
spaces and so that's going to be going
to kind of be like the backing like the
background to what I'm going to talk
about which is kind of some reflections
on like what I experienced when I was
learning about development and how a lot
of the things that people were teaching
me and best practices that I should
follow often came with this other
ideology that I kind of
realize at the time which was the this
searching for absolute truths and
looking for the one true way to do
things and the purging of other people's
ideas that didn't really match with what
was considered my best practice so as
we're heading into this time where the
web platform is changing very rapidly
and it's going to change a lot for CSS
developers as well it's kind of
interesting to look back and this is
something that I have learned to be so
look back at how things changed in the
past and how we responded to that change
to see if we can try to avoid some of
the mistakes that we made before so
before I was a developer I studied
natural sciences at University and
switched to anthropology after a friend
of mine introduced me to it there and it
was one of those things that everyone
has some moments in life where they say
this changed my life and studying
anthropology was one of those for me and
has been so far what I really liked
about it is it has this heavy focus on
looking for assumptions and to do that
you can have have to look through the
history of ideas and one of those is one
of those things where you're not even
necessarily aware of what your
assumptions are until you start
exploring some of the assumptions that
you are aware of and you see this whole
world of ways of thinking that were
created a long long time ago and that
we've kind of just adopted as just given
just a given as part of our lives and
when you do go look at the history of
these ideas as they kind of for CT when
you're not the apology student you get
to see what else was around at the time
some of the kind of debates that were
going on so maybe there's an idea that
came about there now we just take for
granted but at the time it was
controversial and it's kind of fun to
see the you know there were times or
even the smartest of people weren't
entirely convinced by things that now
everyone just assumes is the truth and
when you're doing that you see this sort
of pattern where ideas go through these
cycles where they get iterated upon and
something that didn't really work in its
time later perhaps it sort of makes more
sense in the context that it kind of
reappears this kind of like cycle of
Renaissance and decline and one of these
examples which is the one that I'm going
to use as the kind of example like the
showcase I suppose for for this as I
kind of talk through like HTML and CSS
is a one they sent us back into
pre-socratic Greece to try understand
where a lot of the
ideas when the west came from and so
this guy Heraclitus who i came across
who i don't really remember a huge
amount of the stuff there i studied
about inch increase by remember this guy
because one of the things that he said
really stuck with me and he was depicted
like this by Renaissance painters and it
was really the Renaissance that
rediscovered a lot of the ideas that he
and a few of the other people they'll
talk about came up with and he had
contempt for humankind's he was
portrayed as the weeping the lonely
philosopher and he read a lot of really
obscure philosophy most of which was
lost the time but what's left is kind of
reads almost more like poetry than
philosophy you kind of have to sit back
and think what was he was he trying to
say here but his his main thing was this
like championing of the idea of an
ever-changing world one of his peers
someone called Parmenides had the
opposite view which was that the world
was static and the change was this
surface layer this illusion and that was
the context within which Democritus
found himself he was a contemporary of
Socrates and he was attempting to
reconcile this idea of an ever-changing
world in a static world like how can
these two ideas like live together or
how can I decide you know which one to
kind of support this is how he was
portrayed and he's always portrayed like
he kind of looks a bit evil like I keep
I kept trying to find better pictures
women he's always got like a berry and
like a shoulder out so little after D
and like Heraclitus he also had contempt
on some level for mankind and he was
known as the laughing I'm walking
philosopher like good likeness and from
today's perspective he had some really
modern ideas so he spoke about the
conservation of mass and energy the
indirect nature of perception but his
main the main thing he's remembered for
is the atomic conception of the universe
he came up with a very early idea of how
atoms works basically along with his
with his mental and he used atoms as a
way to try and reconcile these two ideas
the static and a changing world and he
said okay so the world is completely
changing like I combined to that but
when you reduce the world what is this
constituent parts his constituent parts
are all these different types of atoms
and these atoms are like billiard balls
they're like static unchanging and so
this is how we reconcile the exactly
it's both static and unchanging
unfortunately for him Plato and
Aristotle didn't like him they
criticized his work and him as a person
and this static idea this idea of a
static universe that parmenides
suggested was the one that became
dominant and stuck around for about
2,000 years until it was challenged
during the Renaissance and again later
with modern science this is the quote
that I remember from Heraclitus which is
that you cannot step into the same river
twice for fresh waters flowing in upon
you and so I'm reading this and I've
been sent back you know in time in
effect by my lecturers to read about
these guys and I've come across someone
from two and a half thousand years ago
and he's kind of giving me this license
to constantly revisit all the things
that I hold dear all the things that I
seemed to be true which is that was a
whole point of what the my lecturers
were trying to teach me and what he's
really saying is like if I come up to
this metaphorical river and I think it's
the same that's it's not that it's an
illusion necessarily but that's kind of
like an artifact of my way of thinking
I'm not really looking at the world
they've just sort of turned up and be
like oh yeah I've been a dash river
before it's the same but the rivers
different I'm different and the rest of
the world is different so it can't
really be the same when you think about
like what we do or like what I do now
when I write code instead of read this
stuff we're part of like this tech
industry and things are changing all the
time very rapidly and so it's very
interesting to me to see how we kind of
have these assumptions in this field and
kind of understanding that if our
context they're changing what are the
things that we hold dear and that we
seem to be true that may be on so I'm
going to skim over some of the history
of HTML and CSS and provide my
interpretation of that stuff so HTML
used to look a bit like this and you had
like tables and all the styling was
handled with these attributes that you'd
used to control positioning and other
things like font and you had like on
what you're lucky if you had in line
click hands like this and the cost of
this was that as HTML became more
complicated and added all these style
capabilities to meet the needs of what
people wanted to do with the web became
harder and harder to maintain you'd end
up with like huge piles of Dom with if
you wanted to change the look of every
single table so you'd have to like
finally replace in all that
give your templates if you wanted to add
some styles you'd have to go and do that
through every single part of your HTML
on top of that browsers had a lot of
difficulty consistently rendering this
so you'd get different browsers looking
different ways but all you had was a
single interface from which you could
try and control that and users
especially people of a suit with
assistive technologies couldn't kind of
customize the website to look and work
in a way that they needed it to you
around this time in 1994 the w3c was
formed and people started working on
style specifications which eventually
like all coalesced into a single
specification called CSS that became
specification recommendation in 1996 and
if you look through that document
there's a few interesting snippets in
that kind of give you an insight into
the way that people were thinking at the
time and some of their concerns as well
and there's this line here like to
increase the granularity of control over
elements a new attribute has been added
to HTML class so the class attribute was
added for the purposes of CSS so you can
apply your Styles through this interface
rather than like bundling the more than
to the on the actual done itself and
throughout the early parts of the
document of the specification you can
you can see that there's a concern with
what this could where this could bring
about and they tell you not to rely on
this power that they're afraid that this
would affect the universal semantics of
HTML because in effect i could just mark
everything up with leslie a div and then
control the entire presentation with CSS
whereas at least in the past they relied
on some of the HTML to provide me with
that so that was this kind of recurring
theme that they had and the CSS Zen
garden which came about started in 2003
was kind of met to be a way of showing
people like the right way to do things
which was to have semantic HTML and all
this powerful CSS and it was a it was
kind of an example of how you could like
an extreme example I'd say I've have
like a single page of unchanging HTML
this very like that idea of you know the
HTML is forever you don't change that
and you just switch out style sheets and
have like radically different looks so
it's really there to promote the use of
semantic markup and to sort of drag
people away from this table world
but out of this approach and the
reaction against the pre CSS authoring
days came a bunch of these things that
we kind of power it back to each other
this is one of my favorite ones don't
use on semantics last names whatever
they think on semantic means and this is
kind of this is this great quote from a
guy that really helped me learn a lot
about web development i was getting
started called Craigh caimans like his
suit in him and he said your HTML like
diamond should be forever and I only
bought into this this kind of
perspective like HTML as this thing it's
a fixed that's unchanging you just want
to write at once and then all of the
control of the presentation you just do
somewhere else in your CSS and that's
really what I kind of thought and I
applied this thinking to my blog and I
wrote one of the early phases one of the
early passes at my blog with like no
classes at all it was just like pure
descendant selectors this huge pile of
CSS that controlled it all when I spent
every day just me working on that code
that was okay but when I took a break
did some like real work and then came
back and tried to change my blog it was
like really horrible to work with very
difficult and at that point I started to
realize that despite the fact that I've
been like very I probably say militant
about this kind of approach thinking you
know my blog is like an example of a
perfection where you should be writing
HTML I decided this actually wasn't the
way I wanted to work and that it was
very hard for me to you know made my
life difficult basically and so your
diamond Dinah's might be forever but
your HTML probably isn't but this kind
of thinking is like so ingrained and so
much as part of like the general
discourse that it's even made its way
into the html5 spec where they're kind
of like encouraging us to use to write
class names that reflect the content of
the HTML rather than any presentational
aspects and alternative approaches have
been like repeatedly purged as a mark of
amateurs which kind of makes it very
hard for you to suggest not doing it
this way like even now when I taught
sort of at Twitter and I say well maybe
we should just use like an extra like
div like an empty Dave in the corner
here instead of all this crazy CSS it
kind of feel like I slit slightly have
to apologize for making that suggestion
because I know that other people looking
at me thinking what I used to think
about people who said things like this
but if you go back into the CSS spec
there's this other like chunkier his
sentence which is like a structure based
on class is only useful with in a
restricted domain where the meaning of
the class has
mutually agreed upon and I interpreted
this as like as a warning like don't
give up the universal semantics of HTML
this thing that we can sort of pass
around and everyone can have this common
language for a domain-specific language
that you're going to you know you and
your friends who are working on this
website have agreed upon but I think it
contains the seed of an idea that we
abandoned as we've kind of like taking
on this more dogmatic approach to how
you write HTML and that's that we can
use at the main specific we can use the
main specific meaning if we need to and
it's particularly useful we want to
reflect a structure of our presentation
in a way that is separate from the
content because semantics aren't just
for HTML semantics is just meaning so we
can have like presentational semantics
as well I think so I hope I showed that
which like last names were created for
us and look for machines that the
content layer semantics are already
dealt with by HTML and that basically
class names in part no real semantic
meaning two machines at all apart from
their kind of co-option with
microformats and so the purpose of a
class is really for us to have like a
hook so that we can feed CSS and
JavaScript like attached CSS and
JavaScript to you when you start writing
your code a bit like this where you just
think well I'm going to use the class to
basically codify a pattern and I'm just
going to basically imagine this design
is just grey boxes i'm not going to
think oh this is a tweet then you can
end up with these modules these little
chunks of CSS and HTML that are really
reusable because they're kind of didn't
really care what's inside them they just
provide you this structure and so it
doesn't really matter which application
you're working on which part of the
application you're working in you don't
have to constantly rebuild that
so ugly class names the things that
don't look like this at the moment kind
of we there's a tendency to use hyphens
as just word separators basically we
don't really do anything with the class
other than sort of dream it up and think
well this is a this is a class that's
appropriate for what I'm trying to do
you end up with CSS that maps that was a
bit like this where you have your
generic components some kind of
modifiers sometimes you might end up
with it as a chain in class and this is
fine when you're working on a small
scale but as soon as you start working
on larger scale you have like hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds of components
and you have dozens of developers
varying levels of expertise and
experience then it can be quite hard to
to understand when you're reading piece
of Dom like which parts of the Dom like
basically have style control over others
so this bottom group here that's kind of
reaching into an item which is just
purely a descendant so at some point I
just have to make an implicit
association between item and button
group there's no guarantee that maybe
that button group isn't within another
component that also reaches into a
descendant called item but does
something different or if I have button
primary and item all mixed in on the
same download so when I read the CSS ah
of course button and primary associated
but if I button primary an item you know
I have to come make this mapping in my
mind constantly between the CSS that
I've got and the Dom that I have and
kind of try and keep the kind of
association between the two like tightly
coupled in my head and this approach I
found not to be very optimal where is
something like this which if you saw the
top coat talk they kind of talked about
this sort of type of naming convention
which I adapted from the and exs web
architecture that Y and X is as big
company that they build like search
engines or something in Russia and they
have a lot of developers and lot of
websites and this is there like the
latest notation that i've been using
which I stole from montage s which is
another framework and they kind of like
rift with the notation that I wrote
about and came up with this one which i
think is a bit more readable what it
ends up doing is well first of all it
flattens the your selected so everything
has the same specificity so you can kind
of avoid some of the more complex
aspects of working with the Cascade
then it takes every class and tries to
make an explicit association between the
component that owns it in effect and
then the kind of other aspects of that
component so a double hyphen in this
case is used to indicate a modifier so
when i read that class is telling me i
am modifying the button component and
wherever I see button group item thus
indicating a descendant relationship and
it's telling me i'm a descendant and
button group so i know that exactly
what's controlling it and i can try and
avoid if necessary mixing components on
the same Dom node if it kind of helps me
to avoid like things that I'm trying to
like to try and preserve the integrity
of my UI in effect you end up with HTML
that looks a bit like this we have
button group button group heightened
like that is the main sort of structure
of this one component and then inside it
can be well anything but I mean in this
case it's pretty clearly designed to
have a button inside it but the button
component doesn't really know anything
of the button blue component which is
kind of how you want it you want to be
able to write these things in isolation
as much as possible to try and chew off
small parts of the problem rather than
deal with like the whole you I will at
once and as Ryan said earlier ripped
this from earlier today he says like if
you haven't tried if you think of a
boast then you might not have tried it
and so this kind of running theme but
I've got of try these things out don't
necessarily don't dismiss them
immediately because it's unfamiliar to
you give it a try and like my first
reaction was like oh god no but then you
try it like oh yeah this helps like so
some of the problems that I'm
experiencing and makes my life a bit
easier the nice thing about working like
this i found is that i can build these
things as standalone components so i
just have a github repo with the CSS and
a test file to sort of test for
regressions when i change the code in
though and that's it it's basically two
files and the rest is just like croft
for for github and it's just a so I've
had that packed up into a reusable
component which is like a bower package
which is a package manager and then I
can include it like this so i have so
suit is like the this kind of no toolkit
thing that I'm working on that I used to
try and store all these components that
helped me with my dev work and all it is
it's basically a file that just says
these are the dependence
is that I have and it just pulls in all
these other components that I have and
the suit utils itself is another like
six or seven packages so I kind of just
build up this tree of packages and I can
use them piecemeal like one at a time if
I want and I kind of just use this all
the time now they haven't written CSS
for a button for about a year since I
wrote the original suit button I kind of
just tweaked it when I need to but
whenever I need a button I just import
this and it gives me the structural
foundations for a button and then I can
add some style and stuff later like
theming style those later so in the
context of the current development
environment this is quite useful because
it helps me to communicate
presentational structure between the
rest of the team and it can kind of
happen independently of your somatic a
Chanel so you can still keep all of the
you know articles and lists and all that
that you need but then you just kind of
move the styling layer into its own and
so its own semantic layer we don't
really rely on a specific Dom you just
want to kind of have these chunks that
simply give you a presentation no matter
what the DOM is underneath it so this
ties into a related commandment which is
that we shouldn't be using extra
elements and this is something I really
believe that I really hope to champion
the use of pseudo elements for visual
detail ever extra elements but I really
don't like working like this anymore
there's kind of like too much magic
going on and best of this you develop
element you get one extra element and a
lot of the time you want to do something
a bit more interesting so this is how I
might write some code now where I have
like this generic box component and then
all i know is that box has an optional
item in it which is going to be a close
button which is i'm going to use the box
close to like position the close button
up in the corner and then everything in
there it doesn't know about it at all so
i have button which you know keep the
semantics of like a button element but
then I throw some other stuff on there
so I'm like I want to reset that button
to just look like a piece of texts
because I don't want all the border and
the padding and everything that comes
with it and then I'm going to add some
JavaScript into that but I don't a
couple the JavaScript in my presentation
because you know maybe I'll change that
text like class later and then inside
there I have a standalone component
which is an icon which again there's
nothing about everything like this going
on outside of it you can tell that i
have like a modified version of an eye
which is a close icon and that might
have an icon front or something in there
and then a help class to like basically
pull this text off-screen so I just end
up with like for example across in the
corner but screen readers will still be
able to sort of know that it's a close
button so this is kind of quite easy to
read once you get used to it it's kind
of easy to build up like this piece of
you I without having to write any extra
CSS which is something I really try and
avoid to do these doing these days
because like I said a kind of dirty like
CSS at the moment but it's a bit clunky
and messy fortunately it's not 1996
anymore and we've got templating engines
so you can just like hide the
implementation details in a partial and
if I use template inheritance and I can
also specify a part of this component
where something else can live so what i
end up with is somewhere else in my UI
somewhere else in my application i have
a specific part of the UI that just says
i'm going to inherit this shared
component which is like a box with a
close button and then every other part
of the UI that wants to use a box with a
closed bottom can just inherit this
share template I don't have to keep
writing the same class all over my code
making it hard to kind of modify this
piece of view I when I want to make a
change so this is also kind of nice but
we're working with strings and not dong
which is unfortunate there are
frameworks that size that this like
angularjs which is this kind of really
forward-thinking framework that's trying
to look at how the web might be and give
you like kind of remove a lot of the
boilerplate like this stuff which relies
on like a client side templating engine
room or a server-side templating engine
a bunch of conventions this kind of
custom syntax which means that when I
make a component I can't just kind of
give you a way to use it because we're
not really just working with CSS working
with HTML and CSS so I go here's the CSS
like good luck go and write the HTML
yourself and you know I hope it works
out and so the real problem is that we
don't have any encapsulation with CSS so
I can't just create a piece of HTML some
styles and give it to you because you
have to basically buy into the full like
an architectural principle that I've
laid out in order to avoid having Styles
cross these component boundaries which
means it's very hard to have confidence
when you're working in an application
when you drop something in when you
create something for the first time that
it's not going to be affected when
someone goes and works on a seemingly
unrelated part of the UI and ends up
blowing up your website and you know
unfortunately these are desperate
measures that we have to take all this
kind of like ridiculous I mean it kind
of feels ridiculous once you get down
this once you start building it out on
like the level of the deal with large
web applications we have dozens and
dozens and dozens of these templates and
blobs of CSS and then one day someone's
like yo we're redesigning the website
and you have to start again from scratch
or something like that and it's kind of
it's very difficult and so protecting
against different Dom permutations and
all of that is very difficult even for
experienced developers and most of us
maybe have some like familiarity with it
but it's kind of bizarre that some of us
have built entire careers around like
that stuff which is basically nothing
more than trying to defend against all
of the flaws that we experience working
with CSS and HTML but fortunately web
components coming along and they're
going to make like my entire skill set
obsolete because what they're going to
do is push a lot of this into the native
web platform and restore some of my
sanity they're going to add a bunch of
powerful features including
encapsulation when you start looking
through your web components and the
specifications for them it kind of
really highlights the fact that it's you
know we can't just continue to work the
way that we did back in you know as a
reaction against the pre CSS days
because things are going to change like
radically and so all those mistakes that
we've been making well not mistake but
the strong reaction against the pre CSS
authoring days that led to these
dogmatic approaches that were difficult
to work within that we've spent the last
five or more years trying to extract
ourselves from we're going to go through
another period of that coming up with
web components some of it's going to
make our lives much easier but I'm sure
there's going to be plenty of things
that will do that will throw away a lot
of the stuff that we're doing now would
perhaps some of those ideas deserve to
live on and we should maybe be a little
bit careful with that
so the promise of web components is that
they're going to help us make these like
visually rich you is that we're
basically not capable of doing at the
moment and the way that they hope to do
that is by basically relying on more
markup were but the but inside all of
that is this promise of encapsulation
interoperability and reuse which are the
main problems you know almost everything
we've been hearing today I mean
obviously apart from the performance
stuff in that is based around like
attempts to try and solve these problems
attempts to provide a way sorry didn't
meet the dish you I meant I meant really
good way but yeah it's an attempt to
decides that this problem an attempt to
pretend that we don't have to kind of be
aware of how an entire application is
put together in order to work with CSS
and dong and so what web components
going to provide us with is native
templating so we don't have to rely on
kind of your client side templating or
server-side templating language of
choice library of choice encapsulation
for CSS and JavaScript custom elements
so we can kind of define our own bits of
the UI and HTML imports that help kind
of make all the shareable the three key
parts of that the shadow Dom which is
the bit that's going to give us
encapsulation and kind of provide these
Dom boundaries which is what I said that
CSS sucks it kind of does but it's
because we can't basically contain it
within a certain chunk of Dom so it's
kind of a it's the two together that's
the problem element which is how we're
going to define custom elements and
extend native elements and template
which is going to be the part that gives
you like these inner parts have gone so
you can just work directly with Dom you
don't have to have strings or work with
Don but try and like hide it somewhere
in a script tag and then hope that it
doesn't slow the passing down so the way
that that close button might be
implemented in this contrived example is
like this so I have extend I have
element in which I'm telling is
expending the native button element and
then this template which is going to be
the part that like stamps out DOM and
styles and stuff for me whenever I need
to whenever I call on it to be used and
I can sort of control the appearance of
the of the template by sort of attaching
this I think this is correct at the
moment like at host so I tell we liked
the button that I am like making
not look like a button do some other
stuff and then there's like another
custom element in there icon which I use
which is just another basically one of
these but like encapsulated and hidden
somewhere else this is going to help
kind of push these implementation
details somewhere else again in the same
way that we use the partial but provide
us with much nicer interface you can see
we're kind of back to you know what it
was like when you first started which is
you just have a small chunk of CSS and
lower bolt on and a small chunk of
JavaScript and there's a single file and
everything that you need to know about
that this element is in one file and I
can control the level of styles that
flow in and out of this element and I
can have confidence that when I write
some code here that it's going to be
protected which means that I can
suddenly take it and give it to someone
else because it's part of the web
platform as well means that anyone he'll
be working like this we can all write
our own widgets and share them around at
least that's the that's the hope and the
google chrome guys have had this really
nice term for this which is like the
clarity of renaissance like a return to
relying on like attributes and piping
data in like that using markup because
it's okay this is going to be hidden in
a shadow Dom that will never be seen at
the next layer of my application when I
make use of this custom element like
this but like I said it's like a
Renaissance for CSS because we can go
back to you trusting it and almost
anyone could work with CSS that problem
of the well-meaning developer in like
the backend team you has to put a quick
patch in or who has to implement some
new feature who accidentally blows up
part of the site well you know having to
rely on visual differing tools for your
entire website in order to be confident
you haven't destroyed some distant part
of it that is hopefully going to go away
and obviously this is dawn so well
that's much nicer but this isn't
entirely new because as I showed we're
trying to do something like this at the
moment with the tools that we've kind of
built for ourselves but the developer
their browser vendors have also been
doing this so if you bust out chrome
canary and then go into the dev tools
and turn on show shadow Dom then you can
inspect some elements so if you look at
the video element or some of these input
elements like the day Telamon and you
can see their implementation of it
behind the scenes and this document
fragment is basically saying I'm shadow
DOM and that's the part that we never
see but is it exposing it you can see
it's just basically a bunch of divs some
accessibility hope
some ways of exposing parts of the
shadow Dom to be styled outside of the
shadow Dom but only if you specifically
asked for it like if I just said they've
read it's not going to affect any of
this so they have this encapsulation and
they're basically going to be giving it
to it giving it to us and hopefully
that's going to make our lives much
easier so it's okay to use extra
elements we have been for a while and we
probably will be further foreseeable
future well we're coming full circle so
now we have CSS and JavaScript in our
HTML templates again they're not we're
not well we probably aren't going to
have huge style sheets with all of the
style you know somewhere else all the
JavaScript somewhere else and then a big
directory full of templates it's going
to be this small components but
basically to take a web app and scale
that down so that everything is like a
small element in effect and our web apps
will just be a collection of elements
where each layer kind of hiding some of
the implementation details that we don't
need to know about the layer that we're
working in this is going to completely
change our jobs which means that we have
to be prepared to Diaz Heraclitus said
and to step back into the river so we
have to challenge the assumptions that
we're kind of taking with us now because
they're definitely going to change some
of the assumptions that will sort of
develop as we're working with this are
also going to be things that we should
sort of have a second think about before
kind of bashing other people over the
head with them and making the same
mistakes that we did last time around
which is someone comes along try
something out we ask them for not doing
it in the way that we have decided is
the way to be so be open to the way be
open to suggestions from others and the
way that other people like to do things
be prepared to be wrong I guess and to
not just imitate others but to have a
think for yourself about you know what
is it what is the context that i'm
working in now you know is that this is
a problem they're trying to solve the
same problem as I'm trying to solve and
you prepared to have all of your
projects and ideas washed away like the
time like most of the stuff I've worked
on is not going to be relevant in the
next few years and like I'm okay with
that because you know there's no point
clinging on to things that were designed
to work in a different hero I think
that's the main way to avoid basically
stagnating to enjoy working with other
people and to have any hope
doing something original that's it